no
[Música]
bueno quería empezar enseñando unas
imágenes
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y
[Música]
[Aplausos]
sí
[Música]
bueno después de estas imágenes supongo
que la mayoría vosotros estáis pensando
que estoy loco o que simplemente soy una
de esas personas que están hechas de una
pasta que no saben lo que es el miedo
actualmente en el mundo hay un pequeño
grupo de personas que jamás han
experimentado el miedo y estas personas
sufren una extraña enfermedad llamada el
mal de urbat 7 esta enfermedad está
provocada por un daño en la mitad la
cerebral que hace que nuestro cerebro
pierda el control en las emociones que
nos ayudan a gestionar el miedo os
aseguro que no soy una de esas personas
ya que mi vida ha pasado mucho miedo
tengo miedo y siempre tendré miedo
cuando todos vosotros
cuando era pequeño era un niño muy
aventurero me gustaba mucho la
naturaleza me pasaba las horas en el
campo jugando entre piedras cogiendo
bichos un día estaba con dos amigos al
ver y jonás de repente llegamos a una
pared nos llamó la atención
instintivamente jonás y yo empezamos a
subir cada uno por un lado de la pared
álvaro no le motivaba mucho el plan y
ahora la verdad es que no me extraña y
decidió quedarse sentado mirando cómo
subíamos cuando llevábamos más de la
mitad de la pared llegamos a un punto de
no retorno un punto en el que realmente
no veíamos ni cómo subir ni cómo bajar
así que empecé a experimentar una
sensación de miedo que jamás había
experimentado nunca en mi vida empezamos
a temblar a llorar no sabíamos muy bien
que hacer y después de un buen rato
inmersos en ese punto de entre el miedo
y el pánico llegamos a la conclusión de
que la única manera que había salir de
ahí real era continuar subiendo
así que poco a poco con la ayuda de
álvaro yendo de un lado a otro estaba en
pánico
intentando motivarnos conseguimos salir
de la pared
de repente sentí una sensación de alivio
muy grande nos juntamos los tres nos
dimos un abrazo llorando temblando y
pensando en la suerte que habíamos
tenido que jamás nos volveríamos a hacer
nada parecido
a los años había terminar mis estudios
estaba empezando enfocarme por el mundo
de la montaña me llamaba la atención los
deportes de aventura era lo que me hacía
vibrar y a lo que me quería dedicar
me salió la oportunidad de empezar a
trabajar en un hotel como recepcionista
vi que era una buena opción como un buen
medio para conseguir mis objetivos para
ahorrar dinero y seguir mi formación así
que empecé a trabajar trabajaba en el
turno de noche y tenía mucho tiempo
libre después de mi trabajo que dedicaba
a ver películas veía vídeos de
paracaidismo de gente esquiando de salto
base
de gente haciendo cosas increíbles en
sitios increíbles y yo decía yo eso es
lo que quiero hacer
necesito experimentar eso quiero vivir
esas aventuras así que me agarré a esa
motivación para seguir en el hotel y
poco a poco me fui dando cuenta de que
estaba empezando entrar en la zona de
confort de seguridad tenía un buen
sueldo muchas vacaciones contrato fijo
14 pagas
y después de darme cuenta de que estaba
ahí en esta zona que me va a costar
bastante salir de repente un día me
atracaron a punta de pistola
entraron dos atracadores al hotel a las
tres de la mañana rompieron la puerta a
patadas me pusieron una pistola en la
cabeza y me obligaron a abrir la caja
fuerte del hotel
diez años después de esto estaba en el
serac noruego
acantilado incremento alucinante a mil
metros de altura mirando al vacío
temblando a punto de dar un paso para
batir un récord mundial
s otra con el hotel me hizo seguir mi
zona de confort me hizo empezar a
experimentar y aprobar todo aquello lo
que me quería dedicar y lo que quería
hacer
empecé a escalar me di cuenta de que
tenía mucho miedo a la escalada mucho
miedo a la altura tenía todo el rato en
mi cabeza estaba constantemente ese
punto de no retorno en el que había
experimentado en el pasado que no me
dejaba avanzar empecé a marcar pequeños
objetivos que me daba miedo empecé a
cumplirlos y cada vez que cumplía sus
objetivos me daba cuenta de que no era
para tanto de que realmente mi cabeza
estaba haciendo gol me estaba engañando
y estaba actuando como un amplificador
así que decidí a empezar a hacer todas
las cosas que me daban miedo y que
quería hacer
me compré una slack line que es una
cinta para aprender a hacer equilibrio
en el suelo con el objetivo de empezar a
hacerlo en altura
cuando tenía todo interiorizado todo el
aspecto técnico que necesitaba para
subirme a las alturas y poder probarlo
empecé a hacer high line que se llama al
principio os aseguro que me ponía la
cinta temblando intentaba levantarme
envuelto el pánico me caía no conseguía
andar no conseguía respirar no conseguía
otra cosa más que estar bloqueado
así que poco a poco insistiendo porque
cabezón soy bastante decidí que tenía
que seguir experimentando hasta
controlarlo de repente me vi siendo
capaz de
respirar fluir
y controlar mi miedo
y ser capaz de sentir
empecé a hacer saltos con cuerdas
pequeños saltos con cuerda como el que
hace puenting pero yo decidí hacer más
empecé a saltar de todas las formas
posibles de cabeza de espaldas de pie
cada salto era una sensación
completamente diferente
al tiempo empecé a investigar me di
cuenta de que había un equipo de
deportes extremos que están haciendo
expediciones alrededor del mundo donde
hacían saltos realmente increíbles que
yo alucinaba saltos con cuerdas donde
también había gente que hacía high line
donde había gente que hacía salto base y
todo unificado en un grupo de personas
así que yo decidí que quería hacer eso
empecé a investigar me di cuenta de que
iba ni al cañón del perdón que iban a
dar va a ser su próxima expedición así
que coge mis maletas y me planté en el
cañón del verdad en francia
y cuando llegué ahí realmente me di
cuenta de que era más grande de lo que
yo pensaba había pasado de saltar
puentes de 40 a 70 metros de repente
llegar a un cañón donde me sentía como
una hormiga
estuve 12 días de los cuales no dormí ni
uno porque realmente estaba
constantemente pensando si iba a ser
capaz de dar ese paso si realmente
estaba ahí si era necesario lo que
estaba pasando pasarlo tan mal
hasta que decidí hacer ese salto y
cuando hice ese salto tuve una
experiencia y unas sensaciones realmente
increíbles muy difíciles de describir
realmente supe en ese momento que era lo
que quería hacer
así que no paraba de pensar en que yo
quería seguir en ese proyecto al tiempo
ese equipo se puso en contacto conmigo
me dijo que me dijeron que les había
gustado
la entrevista que me habían hecho
después del salto que me veía en una
persona apasionada y que si quería
formar parte de ese equipo así que de
repente me había haciendo cosas
increíbles en sitios increíbles con un
miedo increíble no tenía experiencia muy
poca experiencia era el último mono del
grupo del equipo no me dejaban hacer
casi nada siempre que intentaba hacer
saltos un poco más complicado ser anotó
uno tiene mucha experiencia tú necesitas
seguir entrenando pasaba muy mal pasaba
mucho miedo no era capaz de controlar me
acercaba al acantilado así temblando
no sabía ni dónde estaba asaltada y no
sabían lo que estaba pasando así que
después de una experiencia que tuvimos
en grecia una expedición donde estuve un
mes y medio saltan una playa que era el
paraíso ni tiene un incremento mental
psicológico bastante intenso
sometiéndome a mucho estrés haciéndome
perder el control en el aire hasta
conseguir que fuera capaz de estar en
esa plataforma tranquilamente mis
cuerdas y conectarme mirar dónde estaba
mirar la trayectoria que tenía que
saltar mirar que estaba pasando con
todos los aspectos de seguridad
importantes
poder disfrutar me di cuenta de que en
el miedo había ganado muchos pasos pero
técnicamente no era capaz de controlar
mi cuerpo así que decidí que necesitaba
aprender a andar antes de correr y
cuando llevaba como 100 saltos con
cuerdas empecé a hacer el curso de
paracaidismo
entre en el mundo del paracaidismo entre
empecé a entrenar todo lo que podía una
y otra vez hasta conseguir delimitar
eliminar ese factor aleatorio que tenía
y me causaba tanto miedo porque tenía
muchas carencias
de repente empecé a hacer expediciones
alrededor del mundo
estuve en dubai en unas expediciones más
grandes que se han hecho en los deportes
extremos saltando con gente que eran los
protagonistas de aquellos vídeos que yo
veía en mi oficina ha sentado con mi
traje y con mi corbata
mirando y soñando que algún día me
gustaría probar algo así
después de mucho entrenamiento me
ofrecieron y me dijeron que a esa fecha
en esa fecha era la persona más
preparada el equipo había pasado de ser
el último mono a de repente
y poder cumplir mis sueños y poder hacer
todo tipo de saltos sin ningún tipo de
limitación más allá que mis miedos y mi
técnica
así que ahí estaba en noruega donde
llevaba
cerca de un mes durmiendo una tienda
campaña viviendo con un
os aseguro que el tiempo era bastante
extremo había veces que no podía salir
de la tienda en dos o tres días porque
no paraba de llover recuerdo que
comíamos carne seca a veces dentro de la
tienda otras veces nos levantamos a las
4 mañana porque se había volado la
tienda donde donde comíamos y estaba
toda la comida tirada por el cerdo
así que después de 19 saltos que
necesite de test donde iba midiendo
distancias y viendo si realmente era
probable si era posible seguir avanzando
y seguir cogiendo más metros de altura
batir el récord del mundo
después de esto empecé a ser falto base
donde llevo unos cuantos años
progresando poco a poco
intentando conocer mis límites
y la verdad es que no me siento
capacitado para deciros como os podéis
enfrentar a vuestros propios miedos
pero yo lo he hecho así
estas cosas que quiero que entendáis es
que todas estas cosas que yo hago no las
hago porque sea un loco y no tenga miedo
las hago porque me dan miedo y me
apasionan
creo que mi objetivo nunca se ha sido no
tener miedo ya que el miedo no es una
mancha que se pueda quitar y desaparezca
mi objetivo es hacer las cosas con miedo
y luchar todos los días para que los
límites estén puestos por mi imaginación
y no sean los limpios los miedos los que
sustituyen a mi imaginación muchísimas
gracias
[Aplausos]